start with these Fisher comments so that
we're waiting for as we mentioned in
just about an hour's time from now this
sure seems to in his recent remarks kind
of you know trying to really get out
there that the Fed is ready to raise
rates so even after today's jobs report
do you think he will still be pounding
that table for a rate hike I think he
want to keep his options open what
today's report which is comprehensively
week you've mentioned it weak job
creation week revision week hourly wages
hours worked participation rate back to
nineteen seventy seven levels this is a
comprehensively week report so what that
does I think it takes October off the
table but I don't think it takes to
December off the table I think it's a
50-50 for December and what Fisher is
likely to remind us is that there are
other elements of strength in the US
economy and that monetary policy has to
worry about also asset prices so I think
what you what you'll get is a message
from him that says you know we keep our
options open with data dependent but he
I don't think he will take off December
at this point he won't take it off the
table okay Muhammad but but we had
thought that jobs market was sort of the
one area of growth for the US economy so
what are the other areas that are more
positive and would vote for a rate hike
so if you look at other indicators of
the jobs market they're not as negative
as today's report if you look at
consumer spending including what people
have been spending on cars is not as
negative i'm not saying today's report
isn't bad it is bad i'm just saying that
it's not bad enough for the Fed to
completely remove 2015 as a possibility
of a great hike do you think is we were
talking about earlier with another
economist Michelle Gerard she believes
that the Fed has had missed its window
they should have hiked in September
before this you know new sort of you
knew unveiling of more bearish economic
numbers do you think the Fed made a
mistake and miss their window so I think
they did mr. window I don't think it was
tember i think it was early in the year
okay when you had both international and
domestic factors aligned and then a
couple of things happen the
international factors started becoming
major headwinds then you got financial
market instability that made September
difficult and now there's a question
mark about the domestic elements so yes
they did miss a window and they missed
an important window but I would put it
earlier than Michelle did I would say
was early in the year we've had a lot of
people on Muhammad including yourself
over the last several weeks talking
about the Fed and the impact on the
markets and one such person is howard
marks from oak tree who had this to say
about the Fed and I want to play this
for you Muhammad another reason they
should just bite the bullet and start
doing it is that when they don't do it
everybody takes that as a signal that
they believe the markets too fragile
will do it and that's that's why I think
things have been weeks since since it
didn't happen do you think the Fed
thinks the markets are too fragile
Muhammad I think the Fed is worried that
the markets have lost their anchors and
therefore the Fed has to worry not only
about the impact of its actions but also
its signaling so look today I mean the
feds going to be looking at the market
and say hey wait a minute the stock
market came came back pretty well but
then if it looks at the bond market you
still have us treasuries having moved a
lot in yields downward which tells you
basically the markets are saying you
know what yeah we know the economy is
weak but the Fed will remain stimulative
and that's not where the Fed wants to be
the Fed wants to be completely polar
opposite where the economy is strong and
they're able to slowly normalize
policies so the Fed is in a really
difficult position right now buddy
Muhammad you know your your forecast of
a 50-50 chance in december for a rate
hike is a little bit different from what
the Fed futures where they're trading at
and kind of how their gaming out when
the Fed could raise and I think guys
let's show that bar chart of the
probability of a Fed move and that 5050
scenario Muhammad is more likely now in
March so I you know there's a differ
between your opinion and what we're
seeing is seeing traded right now why do
you think in the markets there in the
futures markets they push it out so much
further so it's always hard to say why
markets do certain things and it's
certainly hard to second guess them let
me tell you why I think December is
50-50 the critical issue for the Fed is
not when it moves first it is the
journey and the Fed has an important
communication challenge between now in
December it has to take the market focus
away from obsessing with the timing of
the first hike to realizing that this
will be the loosest tightening in modern
in the modern history of central bank